you learn more in the middle of a crisis
or when your life has that moment of a
down trot there is more wisdom and
knowledge instincts intuitions
discernment and instincts that are
developed in the middle of a crisis I
would say this is the time for you to
finish that book this is the time for
you to write and finish those songs this
is a time for you to go online and
discover what it is to write scripts
there are million YouTube videos with
people giving you Intel and information
on how to write scripts this is a time
for you to start recording yourself
auditioning and learning how to act this
is the time for you to go online and
watch interviews on some of the most
significant and influential actors in
the world on a TV show called the Actors
Studio where they're not just speaking
on opportunities and movies but they're
explaining in great detail how they've
won about learning and mastering the
craft of acting this is a time that you
should go on Apple and download the
entire season of masterclass you ain't
doing nothin else this is a time to look
within look inward outside of you paying
attention and monitoring the things
that's going on on the exterior this is
a time for us to look to the exterior
right now is a time for meditation where
you just allow the mind to stand still
if you don't know what it is to meditate
because it took me many many years to
figure out what
is meditation because there's a lot of
different forms of meditation and you
just supposed to sit there I don't say
nothing and then you'd be like what they
say working for me
all on YouTube you ain't doing none else
look up different forms of meditation
and try and figure out what works for
you I am in my personal office I have to
tell you I love being it's one of my
favorite rooms in the house and we're
here tonight to talk about our book club
selection which is where's my book okay
here it is we're here tonight to talk
about Hidden Valley Road you know my
mentor Maya Angelou used to always say
that God put a rainbow in the clouds God
put a rainbow in the clouds and if
there's any kind of crisis always look
for what the rainbow is in the clouds
and I think if there's any rainbow we
can find in the clouds right now it is
the fact that we have more time with
ourselves and hopefully more time to
read I'm really excited about that
and to tell you about this book you know
my latest book club selection Hidden
Valley Road this is a book there
everybody's talking about and I'm
telling you it's the extraordinary and
true story of the Galvin family now they
had 12 children first children started
back in the 50s and over the years they
had over 12 children and six of those
children over time was shown to have
schizophrenia at a time when nobody knew
what schizophrenia was it was
devastating and it was a mysterious
illness and people really didn't know
how to explain to themselves and
certainly to their families what it was
so I picked this book because I know
that there are millions and millions of
people throughout the world and families
in particular who are dealing with
the shame with the secrecy with the fear
of mental illness in their own family I
can me is it answered like take
advantage of the situation the this
happened in just now with everybody
being at their homes and stuff for that
and gathering all that attention
everything I talk about is more
important than ever because creating
content from home right now is something
people can actually do and the reality
is is that there's such an opportunity
right now to tell people your story and
to put out content so it's always been a
Content game content is what gets people
to know who you are to them book you
right context is what leads to somebody
wanting to manage you and she like
people change people's careers and
people discover people through word of
mouth or content everybody all eight
nine thousand people in here right now
have to produce content tell your story
tell people that who you are tik-tok for
you bro if you're not putting out three
tick tocks a day I'm gonna punch you in
your beautiful face stop don't fall off
of it use this serendipitous moment to
get on it in most places in the
progressive world you own your time you
get to decide what to do for the next
hour you can sell your time to a boss or
a client and then the client and the
boss controls your time what else do you
own well one of the challenges that we
have as we become adults in the world
and even at 50 or 60 years old become
adults in the world is making the choice
to not sell our time so cheap and making
the choice stone something bigger than
what we're gonna do today and we're
living in this crazy upside-down world
we're in the middle of a slog the
economy is freezing up some people are
challenged by health some people are
challenged by having to deal with their
family all of it is a great excuse to
not own anything to just wait for
somebody to show up with a relief check
or a client or job but I want to argue
today that this is the perfect
to own something to build something
bigger than yourself and what it means
to be a bootstrapper is not that you
need a fancy venture capitalist to write
you a five million dollar check so you
can go public for a billion dollars nor
does it mean that you need to go to the
bank and personally guarantee some fancy
loan by impressing some fancy banker now
what it means to be a bootstrapper is
that you find a problem that you find
people who are disconnected who need to
be connected that you find goods and
services in one place that need to be
somewhere else that you build an asset
and you pay for it because your
customers are so happy that you are in
the world doing the work you're doing
that they eagerly encourage you by
showing up with orders by showing up
with contribution that that cycle
bootstrapping which is technically
impossible lifting yourself up by the
bootstraps is not only possible for an
entrepreneur it is the most common most
productive way forward
and so what bootstrapping is is thinking
very hard not about what your dream is
for how you want to spend your day is
some sort of freelancer who doesn't have
a boss but what does the audience you
seek to serve need who does who do they
need connection to how do we put
together the pleat the pieces so that we
have created value and made the world
better and there are healthcare workers
out on the front lines who are suffering
right now on our behalf to make things
better and if you can do that my heart
goes out to thank you but for the rest
of us there's the opportunity to build
an entity a project one where the people
we are serving would miss us if we are
gone this was the first time that I've
publicly taught meditation for 20 days
in a row so yesterday we finished my 20
days of live meditations every morning
9:30 a.m. la time I was live teaching
the meditation for 30 minutes and I it's
so weird because in my head I'm like
guys I was a monk of course I know the
teach meant it like you know this is
what I did something else but I've never
actually shared it
never actually led I've never liked to
guided meditations in my whole life
digitally and I need them all this time
with my private communities or my
coaching groups or whatever it may be
but I don't do it publicly and I did it
for twenty days and it was like I was
like wow like this is allowed me to find
out a gift that I wanted to share with
people that I forgot I had or I was
immune to the fact that I had it to
share I'm wondering how many people at
this time have you like to find that
they have a talent a creativity and
expertise a genius a gift inside of them
that they don't know because they
realized that there's a pain in the
world that it can solve or that there's
someone in the world that it can help
and that was meditation for me which
seems so obvious in my head but even
that it took this for me to teach it
every day and and it was the most
beautiful like I want to do it every day
now like I'm so pumped by it because
it's such a beautiful experience I want
to start all over again because it was
so meaningful to me let her learn the
people that have helped best time for
crisis to get your relationships deeper
best time to get your relationships
deeper best time to begin to know your
guys better best time to be talking to
you guys better best time to get your
customer relationship better best time
for you to be talking to your employees
your teammates and circulating and how
you doing what's on your mind today I
was walking and strolling just to see if
everybody joking I'm just asking how you
doing how you doing how you doing how
you doing how you doing
boom one of the offices I walk in and
person has a hands on their face I said
how you doing
and she's like can't even answer me I
said well how you doing everything good
she's in tears she was crying for two
minutes straight I see you know what
here what's on you might tell me we
started talking about said once you go
for a walk
say you know that's exert a go break
just get out of here go for a walk and
just maybe take a break from news right
now for a couple hours because maybe you
need to do a media detox for yourself
and she just took the walk right and
then she came hey man thank you for that
sir no problem sometime we need to be
doing that this is where you get your
relationships to go deeper this is the
time that you get your relationships to
be deeper because some people by the way
if you weren't getting your
relationships deeper while everything
was good some of that stuff
it's in your control you're gonna pay a
price for it right now if you really
don't have a relationship with your
partner's vendors employees salespeople
all that stuff because it shows that you
were having strong relationship it's
just that matters today more than ever
before if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there
today's business models with companies
it's a similar format